seront annoncés merci madame la parole
est à monsieur thierry mariani ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre les affaires étrangères jeudi
dernier notre assemblée a adopté une
proposition de résolution invitant le
gouvernement français à s'opposer au
renouvellement des sanctions contre la
russie pour la première fois pour la
première fois nous avons pu nous
exprimer sur cette question et nous nous
en félicitons
inscrite à l'ordre du jour à
l'initiative du groupe l'est républicain
ce texte a recueilli le soutien de
députés qui appartenait à cinq des six
groupes politiques que compte cette
assemblée ce qui prouve qu'au delà de
nos différences lorsqu'il s'agit de
défendre la paix en europe de défendre
les intérêts de nos entreprises de notre
agriculture
nous pouvons nous retrouver la balle
maintenant monsieur le ministre est dans
votre camp
les débats ont montré ces sanctions
pèsent non seulement sur la russie mais
aussi sur notre économie
ce prix nous serions prêts à le payer si
seulement ils avaient une chance de
faire avancer la paix or vous savez très
bien que cela n'est pas le cas
monsieur le ministre vous le savez il ya
très peu de chances que les accords de
minsk soit appliquée puisque les
réformes promises par le gouvernement
ukrainien ne trouve pas de majorité dans
le pays ni au parlement ukrainien
à en croire la presse lors de son récent
déplacement à moscou jean marc ayrault a
même dénoncé les manoeuvres de
retardement qui n'ont que trop duré à
kiev
ma question est donc simple dans les
semaines à venir si l'ukraine n'a
toujours pas respecté ses engagements
soutien soutiendrez-vous une nouvelle
fois la prolongation de ces sanctions
quand je parle de ces sanctions
monsieur le ministre je parle à la fois
des sanctions économiques qui frappent
notre agriculture qui frappe nos
entreprises mais aussi des sanctions
individuelles qui entravent notre
dialogue des parlementaires français et
ukrainiens en sont victimes je pense à
bruno le roux dont je regrette qu'il
soit interdit en russie mais je pense
aussi par exemple à sergueï narychkine
monsieur le président décoré de la
légion d'honneur leonid slutsky décoré
de la légion d'honneur qui ne peuvent
plus venir dans notre pays et qui ne
peuvent plus continuer ce dialogue
alors monsieur le ministre un seul pays
subit la choisir secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
thierry mariani
l'assemblée nationale a adopté jeudi
dernier la proposition de résolution
vous aviez déposé demandant que la
france prône la levée des sanctions de
l'union européenne contre la russie ce
débat a été de qualité je me réjouis que
la représentation nationale
et puis débattre de ce sujet et je crois
qu'effectivement il va éclairer nos
choix futurs cependant la proposition de
résolution qui a été adoptée ne remet
pas en cause la proche fondamentale du
gouvernement sur cette question pourquoi
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire parce que
pour la france
les sanctions ne sont pas une fin en soi
la position internationale de la france
elle est liée à un principe qui est
celui de notre diplomatie de tout temps
quels que soient les gouvernements c'est
le respect du droit international et ses
sanctions vous le savez elles ont été
adoptées suite à l'annexion de la crimée
par la russie et à des violations du
droit international en particulier dans
l'est de l'ukraine du fait en
particulier de soutien apporté par la
russie aux séparatistes pro russes qui
ont mené une guerre dans le territoire
du donbass et nous avons donc lié la
levée des sanctions qui pour nous doit
être l'objectif au respect par la russie
des résolutions de la communauté
internationale et en particulier au
respect des engagements qu'elles mêmes a
prise lors des négociations de minsk
dans le cadre du format normandie que le
président de la république a réuni lors
des commémorations du débarquement c'est
à dire le président poutine le président
porochenko en présence de la chancelière
pour ramener à une résolution politique
de ce conflit
donc oui nous souhaitons que la russie
comme l'ukraine respecte pleinement
leurs engagements dans le cadre de la
feuille de route de minsk les deux
parties doivent respecter leurs
engagements
c'est la seule voie pour une résolution
de ce conflit et c'est ce respect des
engagements de miss qui mêlera à la
levée des sanctions je vous remercie